for more information on tutoring or how
to support moofy university and the
production of more videos please visit
moof university com thank you and enjoy
so consider this situation where we have
three model atoms and each one only has
one electron the for the only difference
between these three is what's going on
in their nucleus the first one has a
plus one charge so it has one proton
second one has a plus two charge two
protons the third word has a plus three
charged three protons so we know that
opposite charges attract so the nucleus
having a positive charge is going to
attract the electron towards it that's
an attractive force an electrostatic
force is pulling on this electron to
pull it in likewise that happens here in
the second situation except it's a more
pronounced because of the higher charge
in the nucleus plus 2 vs. plus 1 now
with the plus 3 that's going to pull
even more so there's a greater
electrostatic force there electrostatic
force is denoted by F sub E and it's
proportional to the magnitude of the
charge so the difference between these
three situations is really their nuclear
charge more specifically their actual
nuclear charge the actual nuclear charge
of the first is +1 second is plus two
and the third is plus three so now
you'll notice they're all pulling on
just one electron that's an important
idea because what happens if there's
more than one electron to answer that
question without kind of want to compare
helium to it a helium plus ok so both of
these have two protons in their new
phase because helium by definition of
having the atomic number of two has two
protons in the nucleus so the atom has
two electrons and those two negative
charges balance out the two positive
charges of the nucleus so the overall
charge is zero whereas the helium plus
because it lost an electron it lost the
negative charge the overall charter this
is plus one so what's going on in the
first case the nuclear charge will pull
on the electron and attract it and what
happens is that electron is the only
electron out
that this nuclear charge is really
acting only on this so that one electron
will quote unquote feel that one
electron feels all of the nuclear charge
that is present here right this this
nucleus and its charge is pulling
entirely on this one electron when
there's more than one electron though
that kind of changes you can imagine and
you might already be thinking that that
you know why are these two electrons so
close to each other shouldn't they repel
the answer is yes they should repel well
let's just imagine that this electron
here gets pulled in such that it's
located here closer to the nucleus okay
it's being attracted to the nucleus
because it's a negative charge of the
nucleus is positively charged they're
attracted but so is this one this one's
also attracted this the second electron
is also being attracted by this nucleus
but you can imagine that if this
electron this this first one here is
present there then this second one
coming it would be a problem because
they would repel that's kind of what
happens the one that's the one that's
here will kind of shield or block this
one away repelling it away causing that
one to be repelled okay so what's
happening here is that each electron
quote-unquote shields the other from
getting closer to the nucleus and what
happens is that the nuclear charge is
not felt or experienced in its entirety
by the electron so it's kind of like
this nuclear charge is being dispersed
between the two right as opposed to
pulling on on each of them with its
entirety ok so this concept is called
electron shielding so even these two
these two HD and HD+ haan ag+ both have
the same actual nuclear charge because
their nuclear charge in both cases is
too but AG plus has the greater
effective nuclear charge and 'he has a
lower effective nuclear charge because
the charge that's felt by the electrons
here and here is less than the charge
the electron field is over here okay and
it's due to this shielding basically
what happens is that when there's more
electrons there's more shielding and
when there's more shielding be if the
the nuclear charger sort of dispersed
between the different electrons the
greater number of electrons and thus
there's a lower effective nuclear charge
which is denoted as ze FF so the
effective nuclear charge what is it
exactly it's the actual nuclear charge
minus the effect due to electron
shielding and that's often represented
in this equation Z eff representing
effective nuclear charge equals Z actual
actual nuclear charge minus shielding is
the effective shielding so you can kind
of think about it as this this nuclear
charge being sort of dispersed between
the different electrons that that are
floating around it whereas in one in the
case where there's just one electron
that electrons feeling every single
aspect of that nuclear charge okay so
now the effective shielding is more
pronounced between inner and outer shell
electrons so in the previous case they
were kind of in the same energy level
but now it's a situation where we have
more than one energy level right so the
inner shell electrons they shield the
outer shell electrons even further even
more to a greater extent then enter the
electrons sort of shield each other in
the same energy level so this this these
are the outer shell electrons out here
easily outer shell that one there that
one there those are the outer shell
electrons
and these guys on the inner shell are
actually sort of blocking the electrons
out here from being felt by the nucleus
right or these electrons are going to be
able to feel the entirety of this
positive charge in the nucleus because
these electrons are kind of blocking
them out so what's happening is that the
outer shell electrons are repelled away
and shielded by the inner shell
electrons so you should you could sort
of be able to draw from this that when
we're talking about the shapes or the
different types of orbital is the S
orbital p orbital d-orbital an F orbital
with as you go from s to P to d/deaf
you're you're going up higher in energy
because the electrons are more likely to
be further away from the nucleus thus
the effective nuclear charge as you go
from s to P to d to f is decreasing the
effective nuclear charge increases going
to the left right because the electrons
are more likely to be closer to the
nucleus in those types of orbitals in
the S orbitals so this concept right of
shielding end of an effective nuclear
charge those two concepts are important
and we'll come back to them actually
when discussing periodic table trends or
periodic trends okay however as far as
this series goes this impacts the energy
or the energies of atomic orbitals with
multiple electrons because we said that
the orbitals in hydrogen which only has
one electron if there is the same if the
orbitals have the same principle quantum
number then they have the same energy
that's not the case in atoms with
multiple electrons and this is part of
the reason why because of this aspect of
shielding an effective nuclear charge
okay that's what we'll see in the next
video so I hope that video was helpful
thank you for watching if you found that
video helpful don't forget to Like
comment
and share with friends thank you and
happy studying